>> Greg: A SENATOR ASKED WHO'S
THE BLAME BLAME FROM BAGGAGE
CLAIM.
HE WAS SO COULD BE DISGRACED HE
EVER IN CHARGE OF NUCLEAR WASTE?
I SPEAK OF THE SAM BRENTON, THAT
IS HIS MUG SHOT.
THE NONBINARY HAIRLESS AND
CARELESS FORMER JOE BIDEN ENERGY
OFFICIAL BIND TO LUGGAGE THEFTS
IN MINNEAPOLIS AND VEGAS SINCE
WHO SUPPORTED ON THE AIRPORT
FOLLIES HE'S LOST HIS JOB AS
DEPUTY ASSISTANT SECRETARY WHICH
DISPOSITION OF THE PERMIT OF
ENERGY'S OFFICE OF NUCLEAR
ENERGY.
THROUGH TRAGEDY IS THAT TITLE
WILL NEVER BE A WHEEL OF FORTUNE
PUZZLE.
HE HAS SOILED IT.
THIS EMBARRASSING SCANDAL RAISES
TWO VERY IMPORTANT QUESTIONS.
HOW THE HELL DID THIS NOT KIDS
GET A SECURITY CLEARANCE WHEN I
CAN'T IS THERE ANY RED
LIPSTICK'S REP LEFT FOR THE REST
OF US?
[LAUGHTER]
JUMPER ALSO WAS OR DEMANDING
ANSWERS TO BOTH THOSE QUESTIONS.
I'M LYING.
BUT WHATEVER IS CALLING ON THE
ENERGY DEPARTMENT TO LAUNCH
INTERNAL INVESTIGATIONS INTO A
SECURITY CLEARANCE PROCESS.
SAYING IT'S AMERICA'S SECURITY
INTERESTS THE D.O.E. HAD JUST
DONE A LITTLE SOCIAL MEDIA
VETTING THEY WOULD'VE FOUND A
TREASURE TROVE OF PICKS OF SAM
ENGAGED WITH THE PUPPY PLAY.
IN A FOREIGN OBJECT IS PROBABLY
NOT A CHEW TOY.
WILL COULD BE USED AS ONE.
AND NOT THAT ANYTHING WRONG WITH
PUPPY PLAY, AS LONG AS IT'S
BETWEEN TWO CONSENTING ADULTS
WHO TEST NEGATIVE FOR HEARTWORM.
SO THE SENATOR WANTS A PROBE
INTO HIS BIDDING PROCESS, PRO?
[LAUGHTER]
SEVEN TELLS ME SAM WILL WELCOME
THAT WITH OPEN...
ARMS.
AND WHAT HE THINK IT TOOK SO
LONG TO FIRE THE SKY?
>> I THINK THE ADMINISTRATIVE
WANT TO FIRE A NONBINARY
INDIVIDUAL ACTING IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE BIGGEST HANGUPS WERE
SAM, DID PASS A SECURITY
CLEARANCE.
THAT IS A GOOD QUESTION THAT
SENATOR IS ASKING HOW THAT
HAPPENED?
BUT DO YOU WANT TO BE THE
FEDERAL AGENT WHO'S GOING TO THE
SKY'S BACKGROUND IS A GET BACK
ON A PHOTO AND SOCIAL MEDIA BE
IN LIKE, SUED THINK YOU CAN KEEP
NUCLEAR SECRETS?
HAD TO BE THE NONWHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE COULD BE IGNORANT FEDERAL
AGENT WHEN YOU SHOULD ASK
QUESTIONS OF A NONBINARY
INDIVIDUAL AND GO TO THE
JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION YOU
HAVE TO SAY, SO I'VE GOT
CONCERNED ABOUT YOUR NONBINARY
INDIVIDUAL AND IT'S VERY WOKE
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU DON'T BE THE FEDERAL AGENT
THERE CERTAINLY A REALLY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION SHOULD BE
HAD ABOUT HOW YOU BET, THAT
SOMEONE WHO LIVES LIKE THIS SO
PUBLICLY IN THE FUTURE WITHOUT
BEING RUDE I GUESS.
>> Greg: IF SAM IDENTIFIES AS
A DAY, THAT SHE COULD DOUBLE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS CUSTOMER
BECAUSE OF VOMIT THEY ALL GET
LOTS OF STUFF.
>> Tyrus: AND I'M A CITY.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU IDENTIFIES
MINNEAPOLIS.
[LAUGHTER]
KAT, CAN YOU LOOK AT US FROM THE
OPPOSITE PERSPECTIVE?
SUPER BIZARRE STUFF ONLINE AT
SOME IT'S LIKE YOU CAN'T BE
BLACKMAILED.
>> Kat: PLUS, ARE WE
INSINUATING THEY DON'T DESERVE A
SECURITY CLEARANCE JUST BECAUSE
YOUR LITTLE?
>> Greg: THAT'S NOT A LITTLE.
>> Kat: THAT DOESN'T MATTER.
I DON'T WANT TO DO ALL THE
NONSTUPID ALL STEALING PEOPLE.
HE'S A, OR DAY IS A, THEY IS A
CRIMINAL, THEY IS A STUPID
CRIMINAL.
I'M SURE THAT THERE IS LOTS OF
PEOPLE EVERYWHERE.
THEY'RE VERY QUALIFIED.
AFTER THAT THIS PATRIOTS.
[LAUGHTER]
IF YOU WANT TO DO THAT GO AHEAD
AND DO THAT TILL WE STEALING
PEOPLE'S LUGGAGE REPEATEDLY FROM
AN AIRPORT.
>> Greg: I HAVE THIS IDEA
SHOULD WE HIRE HIM?
>> Tyrus: NO.
[BLEEP] NO.
>> Greg: TRAVEL CORRESPONDENT.
NO?
>> Tyrus: NO, STOP.
HE'S NOT QUALIFIED FOR THAT
EITHER.
[LAUGHS]
>> Erin: HE DIDN'T CHECK A
BAG.
>> Tyrus: ANNA SINGH IS OUR
THIS INDIVIDUAL.
>> Maria: SO STRANGE.
YOU HAVE TO BE BULLIED.
YOU CAN ASK THE CALL SUMMING OUT
BECAUSE YOU'RE AFRAID THEY'RE
GOING TO INSULT HIM, HER BECAUSE
SHE IS BINARY.
I THINK YOU DO THE CRIME YOU DO
THE TIME.
>> Greg: HERE'S THE THING I
DON'T LIKE MISSING OUT.
I DON'T THINK IT'S ABOUT
NONBINARY IT'S OBSCENE OUT ABOUT
NONBINARY IT'S ABOUT FETISHISM
OKAY?
THIS IS A FETISHIST WHO HIDES
BEHIND THE JEN TREND.
KIND OF LIKE THE GIANT IMPLANT
LADY FROM OTTAWA, CANADA,
CORRECT?
YOU CAN APPLAUD.
[APPLAUSE]
IN YOUR FACE.
PEOPLE STILL CARE ABOUT THAT
STORY.
I WILL WON A PULITZER.
MY POINT BEING THAT FETISHISM IS
DIFFERENT THAN GENDER.
IF I DECIDED I DECIDED I WANT ON
THE.
THAT'S PART OF BEING NONBINARY,
THEN THAT MEANS THAT PEOPLE CAN
OBJECT.
IT IS A FETISH, IT'S NOT
IDENTITY.
>> Tyrus: WHATEVER YOU CHOOSE
TO DO OR NOT DO IN MY CASE THE
BEDROOM NEEDS TO BE IN THE
BEDROOM.
WHAT BOTHERS ME ABOUT THIS IS
BOTH OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
YOU MENTIONED, BOTH CUEVAS
SCIENCE IS IN THE SHOP PEOPLE
WERE BORN MEN.
AND IF THEY STAYED MEN COME STAY
WITH ME, IF THEY STAYED MEN, IF
THEY HAD CONTINUED TO IDENTIFIES
A MAN, AND THE GOD OF THE
POLITICS AND THEY HAD THESE
BEHAVIORS THERE WOULD BE OUT OF
A JOB AS SOON AS HE WENT OUT, AS
SOON AS GUTFELD TIES HIM UP AND
MAKE SOME BERKELEY DOG DOSE OF
TOMB, YOU WOULD BE FIRED NO
QUESTIONS ASKED.
DON.
[APPLAUSE]
IS NOT FAIR, IT IS NOT FAIR TO
BINARY PEOPLE.
THE GENDERS HOW THEY FEEL IS NOT
THE DUDE WHAT THEY'RE DOING IN
THEIR BEDROOM AND IF THEIR
SEXUALITY THAT, THEY'RE NOT
EXPOSING THAT.
AS LIKABLE ACROSS THE BOARD YOU
CAN BE WHATEVER YOU WANT TO BE,
BUT YOUR MORAL CODE HAS TO
SUMMING DO WITH IT AND THEY
THROAT THE MORAL CODE AND THAT'S
WHY THERE'S NO VETTING.
JUST CHECK THE BOX, YOU CAN FED
HIM.
OR HER, OR WHATEVER, I'M SORRY.
WAS IT SAM CHRIS MARK YOU CAN
FED SAM, BECAUSE HE IS THE
FIRST.
AND MIGHT'VE SOME STUFF THERE
FOR MAKING HISTORY HERE.
>> Greg: ARGUED BE COVERING
THIS?
>> Maria: WE HAVEN'T DONE A
LOT ON THIS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: I CALLED A NEWS
PORCUPINE EVEN THE MEDIA IS
AFRAID TO TOUCH THE STORY IS
OUCH, I MIGHT PICK MYSELF.
>> Maria: FINANCIAL SECURITY
WHO IS VETTING THESE PEOPLE?
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Greg: HE WAS IMMUNE, HE WAS
A PORCUPINE NO ONE WANTED TO GET
CLOSE.
AND I WE ALL LEARNED A VALUA